well my friends inflation has come in
and it has come in low and if we want to
participate
in this ridiculous game wherein we say
well if inflation going up was Joe
Biden's fault then inflation coming down
must be credited to Joe Biden now you
and I and many of the people that are in
our audience kind of prefer to operate
more in the real world where we don't
play these political games with gas
prices and with inflation so let's not
play them let's just look at the data
and understand that inflation is a
global phenomenon and we're going to
look at Global numbers and we're going
to punch the microphone as I often do
when I get excited and we'll hopefully
have an understanding of the fact that
this is something that shouldn't really
surprise us because it's been the most
likely trajectory for a while although
in general we are not particularly good
as humans at making economic predictions
it did seem as though inflation peaked
some months ago and it would be lower by
the end of the year and indeed it is so
let's start with the data CNBC reporting
consumer Prices rose less than expected
in November up 7.1 percent from a year
ago the Consumer Price Index Rose just
0.1 percent from the previous month
increased 7.1 percent from a year ago
compared with respective estimates of
0.3 and 7.3 percent core CPI the
Consumer Price Index Rose 0.2 percent on
the month and six percent on an annual
basis compared with respective estimates
of 0.3 percent and 6.1 percent stocks
soared uh the Dow is as of right now up
about 400 points inflation adjusted
average hourly earnings for workers Rose
0.5 percent for the month though they
were still down 1.9 percent from a year
ago now whenever we do these numbers
there's confusion David wait
are prices up or are they down what does
it mean it but if Prices rose how are
they down remember that there are two
components to this what happened last
month and how does adding the data from
last month change the last 12 months of
inflation so remember
we want a little bit of inflation we
have an economy and I know that this
gets into well do we really buy into
this traditional economic stuff and I
get that I get that but
the sort of standard view is you want a
little bit of inflation a little bit of
inflation is good why if you have a ton
of inflation Things become unaffordable
so people stop buying which hurts
businesses so they lay people off and
then those people have no money to buy
stuff and it's bad for the economy
that's too much inflation if you have
deflation it might sound good you might
say Sir ma'am it's cheaper stuff is good
deflation sounds good no it's not good
for the economy why
if you expect prices to continue
declining if you're looking at a car
right an electric vehicle for example
and you expect because we're in a
deflationary situation that if you wait
six months the prices will be lower you
wouldn't buy the car that's bad for the
businesses the employees at the electric
car businesses get laid off because
nobody's buying cars because you expect
prices to go down so the idea is a
little bit of inflation creates an
incentive to buy now rather than later
it's not so much that Things become
unaffordable and that is where economic
growth comes from now believe me I'll be
the first to tell you those sort of
completely rational actor economic
analyzes lack a very real component I am
with you but those are the oranges for
lack of a better term of why a little
bit of inflation is good getting us back
to the numbers
in there was a little bit of inflation
last month but compared to November of
21 it was lower so when we replace in
the one-year inflation number the
November 21 number with the November 22
number year over year inflation is lower
okay so that's that uh Dow surge is 400
points as investors cheer the light
inflation report you know I don't put a
lot of stock in these types of headlines
I I think it's important to remember
that
uh you know to some degree
this has been predicted for months so if
markets were completely efficient and
and rational
this this new data would have already
been priced in it doesn't really make
sense that the Dow pops because the data
was what it is but the expectation on
paper was of slightly higher inflation
and it came in lower okay if you're in
the market it's a good day and as many
of you know much of the return in the
markets happens on just 10 days out of
the year today may be one of those days
lastly remember that inflation is a
global phenomenon and when you look at
the inflation rates these this is data
from October in some countries and
November in some you see that among
wealthier and larger Nations Nations
that are part of this list we're looking
at the trading economics.com list you
see that the US is sort of like right in
the middle now with year-over-year
inflation at 7.1 percent down from you
know the high eights and you see that
for example in Italy and in the UK
inflation is significantly higher
uh
whereas in Brazil and France and
Singapore and Spain inflation is lower
than in the U.S has very little to do
with Joe Biden Global phenomenon U.S
sort of like right in the middle there
so this is overall I believe a good
thing inflation has been too high it has
been a strain on on American budgets and
hopefully this continues and we can get
down again we're just we're not good at
this but it would be nice to continue
seeing the year-over-year numbers ticked
down over the next six months where
maybe we can get to like the low fives
High fours by summertime and that would
be historically much more pleasant I
think is the word that I would use so
that's the latest on inflation when
you're working during the day when
you're on the go and you're in the mood
for something sweet don't reach for the
candy bar go for something that's just
as good but without the sugar and carbs
our sponsor monk pack makes delicious
keto granola bars and nut and Seed bars
they're tasty crunchy gooey sweet and
salty I love them but each bar has only
one gram of sugar two to three net carbs
and about 150 calories perfect if you're
doing keto or low carb or low sugar you
can have a treat that feels indulgent
and satisfying without the guilt monk
pack comes in flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate caramel sea salt they just
launched two new flavors I love peanut
butter cocoa chip and dark chocolate
cocoa my favorite thing is the texture
I've tried a lot of these nut bars
granola bars monk pack is superior if
you don't agree you get your money back
and it is the perfect holiday gift go to
monkpak.com and get 20 off your first
order with the code Pacman the link is
down below